yay welcome back everybody we are doing
this this is the seventh week in a row
that we've gotten together and done
something cool in basically on the
computer in CG if this is your first
time welcome to the stream the idea here
is basically I understand not all you
guys have the same programs that we all
got currently I'm using cinema 4d that's
what I'm usually working in sometimes I
use After Effects on the stream of use
that once or twice but you know I get it
not all you guys have cinema 4d and not
all of you guys have After Effects but
this time on Saturday from usually 12:00
to 3:00
you know 12:30 to 3 this is the time
that we all have to come together and
practice the stuff we love doing
practice the stuff that we want to get
better at this is the time and hopefully
you guys are doing this once a day for
about an hour you know if you suck at
something and you're trying to get
better at something do it once a day for
an hour that's all you need wake up a
little earlier and focus on your craft
wake up a little earlier and go for a
run wake up a little earlier and draw
whatever you have to do to get better at
the thing you're trying to get better at
just do it once a day for an hour and I
promise you if you stay with that if you
keep consistent you will get better I
promise and it's like the most
satisfying thing in the whole world so
this week Saturday is our time to get
together and do it together right and
you know over the last 7 weeks this last
7 Saturdays this thing has grown into a
really really cool thing I always look
forward to it every single week even
though I'm busy as heck this is the time
to get together and do something cool so
welcome welcome
let's see announcements announcements so
if you guys don't already know there is
a discord channel that you guys can post
all of your work on you can request
tutorials and all this and that and it's
been slow
slowlyslowly being built out every
single week so I really appreciate you
guys using that if not it's in the
description of this video here you can
go go ahead and sign up for the discord
chat what else what else um anything
else
oh so today Melanie actually made a
really nice suggestion here in the chat
and she said how about doing that space
scene today in honor of the late Freeman
Dyson and I think that is a fantastic
idea
so today we're doing a space scene I'll
be using cinema 4d and if you guys want
to follow along in cinema 4d there's
actually a really cool website that you
can download free high-res space
textures and that that is solar system
scope comm slash textures and I actually
dropped a link down in the chat I will
do it again for you guys
and there's actually a Video Copilot
there is a Video Copilot plug-in called
orb and I think orb is free I'm pretty
sure orb is free wrong Video Copilot
and if you guys want to follow along and
don't have cinema 4d maybe consider
downloading orb it is a free plug-in by
the man the legend Andrew Kramer at
Video Copilot dotnet head over there
download orb and start messing around
with some of that stuff you know even if
you have to just leave this stream going
on in the background turn down the
volume watch Andrew Kramer do his thing
in orb and make a cool spacing and then
come back to this stream and let's see
how we're all doing together so um let's
let's hop in so yes download your
textures y'all from that website that
that solar system comm website solar
system sculpt comm slash textures and
you can see here you can get all
high-rez 8k textures from all the
different planets you got Earth Day
night clouds normal Maps specular map we
got stars we have fictional planets and
this is just a super super cool website
with a lot of cool assets so go ahead
and download those I'm gonna hop into
cinema 4d and get started right away
last thing here this this is the time if
you haven't already joined the Spotify
playlist it's it's in the description of
this video guys it's called what is it
ambient music for VFX and editing it's
just a little playlist I put together
for you guys right now I am listening to
an artist called warmth and I just
discovered this guy a few weeks ago and
I'm in love with his album home so I am
listening to currently the album home by
warmth I wish I could play on the stream
but I can't monetize if I do that and if
you go to the bottom the second half of
the album is all basically just remixes
so I'm listening starting from the top
and working my way down and this is
gonna be the perfect time for for some
ambient music so let's get to it
CG studio thanks for the super chat if
you guys don't know that is a super chat
I enabled that thing like two weeks ago
so I appreciate you says hey how are you
doing what's the plan for today CG
studio we're doing a space scene so
let's get the ambient music going and
jump on in
oh you guys you guys got some good
suggestions what about the Mitch Meyers
deep void pack I don't know anything
about that
oh man welcome just welcome everybody
welcome it's kind of tough to do you
know to talk and do this and read the
comments but hey we're gonna make it
happen y'all okay let's just render our
scene right now I have I'm using octane
right if you guys are using Arnold or
redshift that's fine too and I think
they're basically all kind of very
similar but I got an octane sky right
now and I'm using HDR I linked from
greyscale gorilla calm they are the best
source for tutorials really it's how I
learned how to use cinema 4d and they
have a lot of great plugins and assets
so head on over to greyscale gorilla
comm and check out their goodness and
actually we'll be using all there's a
lot of their stuff today you'll see here
so we want to make a space scene and
what do you need for a spacing well you
need to plan it probably so that's why I
have a little sphere here let's let's
scale this guy up I don't know you're
not gonna get it as big as a planet but
um let's just set it to like I don't
know 20 meters zoom on out here so it's
a fairly larger scene right segments
let's go to 200 we want to smooth this
guy out let's go maybe even 300 and see
what that does for us because we're
gonna be adding some displacement and
some normal maps to actually pardon me
well I have to actually give this planet
some texture in some shape you know
we're gonna put some clouds on it you'll
see some nice shadows all over this
thing it's gonna be sweet
I'm gonna delete the plane and let's
just start with a basic material here so
let's save our scene first because you
all don't want to
have a program crash on you do all this
work and not save your scene right what
is the space scene and OneNote so after
I did that stream last week with the you
know with the tree and the sticks and
the heads and everything I had to go to
Texas and do a whole crazy week in Texas
with the black rifle coffee company and
corridor digital and man it was some
hard hard work and I didn't have time to
finish that render but I'm gonna finish
that render because it's so freakin cool
and I want to get it done it'll it just
needs like another 30 minutes worth of
work so hopefully we'll get a nice nice
little render here today and then after
this stream I'll probably just wrap that
that other one up from last week y'all
are awesome you all are awesome I really
appreciate your comments and your eyes
is uh you guys's enthusiasm for these
streams hello from India Rajdeep welcome
welcome welcome what am I gonna make I
want to make it out to India one day I
know what will happen I'm very excited
for that
um Bebo Bebo says I can never think of
anything to render man I was kind of in
the same boat I love drawing I love
drawing since I was a kid and I could
never think of something to draw but
something that always helped me is like
I'm a big video game or two so I will
get inspired by video games and I drew a
lot of different video game stuff and
you know what let me show you guys let
me show you guys something this is my
old art book here this is old old stuff
and I could never figure out what to
draw but I kind of just drew the people
I enjoyed and the games I enjoyed so
I'll give you an example here the man
the man himself Bruce Lee this guy has
inspired Jenner
upon generations of people and being a
martial artist myself this man is a huge
inspiration for me so what did I draw
when I was there's no date on this thing
but it was Bruce Lee because I really
love Bruce Lee right here we go with
some jet Lee this is actually from a
video game I think it was called rise to
honor or something like that or rise I
forget is it was Jet Li's video game as
a martial arts game loved it so much and
I just drew something that I enjoyed you
know Jet Li's cool and I love this video
game so I drew that and now it's the
same foreigners you can't figure out
what you want to render well that's why
I have you know a whole bunch of art
books up here and if I ever am in need
of something to render I'll flip through
these art books and I'll start looking
through some different stuff or even
photography books and I'll flip through
these photography books and figure out
like what do I want to draw what do I
want to render I have no idea what
what's inspiring to me right now so I'll
flick through all this stuff and get
some get some examples who here's um I'm
a big Tekken faint oh God
I'm a big Tekken fan so of course Jin
from Tekken and your boy Leonidas what
else I got
what else do I got in here oh this is
old man 2005 2005 one of my favorite
games of all time Ratchet & Clank I just
drew the cover because I didn't know
what the draw but I'm like hey I like
Ratchet and Clank so I'll draw that long
story short
draw draw what you love all right so
let's let's load these textures in
hopefully at this point you guys have
downloaded those textures I'm gonna make
an octane glossy material drop it onto
the sphere and let's double-click on
that guy go into the node editor save
your scene and let's start dropping
those textures in here oh come on
already with the crash man I feel like
when I drag and drop textures that's
when I get crashes let's read some
comments cgi checklist welcome welcome
you just submitted animation on discord
for you to critique absolutely thank you
thank you um do you think I'll ever do
Houdini Houdini yes I will I will
Houdini is basically advanced mode for
any CG stuff so in time in time I will
do some Houdini stuff but right now
we're doing a little space scene FD yay
let's keep up the inspiration let's keep
let's keep going down that path right
hey Clint are you using full version of
octane or rental this is a full version
I got the full version of octane going
here today but I'm sure you can do it
with the rental version um dude Arthur
yes Ratchet and Clank is one of the best
video games of all time it is my
childhood jak and daxter Ratchet and
Clank spyro crash bandicoot man such
good times alright so I'm just gonna
load these materials normally here I'm
in the the diffuse tab I'm gonna
just load an image and let's go ahead
and load our Earth Day texture you just
had know on that and look at that we
have you know there's Australia down
there
nice little globe
beautiful beautiful let's keep it going
so back in the texture let's go to the
normal map and load the normal and this
is again all free textures I'm using
from that website that I dropped in the
chat it is let me just do that again for
you guys
solar system scope comm slash textures
boom there y'all go CG studio things
again for the super chat man how have I
ever tried blender he asks I have not
actually but blender is a fantastic
program because it's free and it's super
super powerful so if you guys want to
follow along please download blender
download blender it's free and I think
octane is actually free for blender so
let's keep moving here we have a
specular map here let's load this in
earth specular so basically what that's
gonna do is I'll show you guys here
let's load this in everything that's
black the landmass it's not going to be
reflective but everything that's white
is going to be 100 percent reflective
right so you can see that here where the
water is reflective but the landmass is
not Simon Alexander again thank you for
the super chat uhm you in the corridor
creme inspire me to no end yes dude
thank you so much thank you thank you
let's keep it up man keep working on the
craft keep working on your dreams once a
day
for an hour and then on Saturdays
together right for a few hours and we're
gonna get better we're gonna get better
together it's gonna be awesome okay we
got a normal map we got a diffuse map we
have our specular map right let's keep
going I think next up is there's a
nighttime color pass there's also clouds
all right so let's get these clouds in
here how we gonna do that pretty easy so
I'm actually gonna duplicate this sphere
here and scale it up just a little bit
so control-c control-v will duplicate
the sphere and instead of 200 or instead
of 2,000 centimeters I'm going to do two
thousand one hundred centimeters so it's
just a little bit bigger I'm going to
also duplicate the texture down here so
let's go down control and drag this
texture out and let's rename our stuff
that's earth this is clouds save our
scene delete the earth texture from the
new sphere we made drag and drop the
clouds texture on the new earth we just
made let's rename this stuff to clouds
earth this is our camera we have a
little camera going and we have an HDR
eye right now we're gonna switch that
out pretty soon yeah we're gonna get
some we're gonna get some HDRI stars in
our scene here and actually let's let's
light this real quick before we continue
so I'm actually gonna go into the octane
sky here this is where I have my HDR I
map and if you look here in the little
viewer here you can see the HRI map is
sorry the HDR I map is basically just
like a stairwell you know with some
light coming in some top light it's a
nice little scene to light this if it
was like a globe in a classroom or
something but we're not in a classroom
we're gonna be in space so if you click
on I think there's a big there's a bunch
of different ways to add HDR eyes to
your scene but specifically since I'm
using HDR I linked in the HDR I browser
from greyscale gorilla
they make it super easy so let's set
that up real quick if you guys are
following along I'm just gonna make an
octane sky here by clicking this button
and this is custom I made this little
setup here of all my little octane
buttons and if you're using octane you
can go to I believe materials no I'm
sorry I go to objects and hgri
environment and that will make an HDR I
octane sky here now if you click right
click on this guy and you do have hgri
link let me show you how easy this is
you just click on that you select your
HDRI environment tag you drag and drop
the little texture into the link and
already you launch the browser and you
have all these HDR eyes you can choose
from and make it super easy now they are
actually kind enough to send me their
new HDR I pack it's a space pack and
those the guys over at greyscale are
just the freakin best I've met all of
them personally I love them so much
there's such great people and they
hooked me up with NHGRI space pack early
it's coming out later this year so if
you guys are looking for something cool
like that then please you know go to
grey schoolgirl I give them a little
check this isn't sponsored or anything I
just really really do love these guys
let's start with let's start with
something like this for right now now we
do need a Sun we need a pair it with a
Sun so if I make let's see an octane
daylight or if you go to objects lights
octane daylight now there's also octane
planetary but I've never messed with
this I don't know it I don't even know
what this does the planetary environment
which is funny we're doing a space
tutorial but I'm not going to use the
planetary environment
in octane right now I'll just use the
daylight and I'm probably doing this all
backwards the sky color we will set to
actually we're gonna use our HDRI map as
the sky color so if you check the box
here mix sky texture it's gonna use the
HDRI image that you have set up and
hopefully why is that not working
mix sky texture should be working there
it is so now you have your sunlight
which is pointed in the direction of
this line let's just come at it from you
know something some side light action
we're gonna get this looking nice and
pretty
I'm gonna switch out the background here
with just some classic stars okay so
let's get our let's get the clouds going
so this is gonna be pretty sweet
basically if you go into the little
clouds material we have set up I'm gonna
go into the diffuse or go into the node
editor here and let's get rid of the
normal map let's get rid of the specular
and let's get rid of even the diffuse
and if we go into the diffuse let's load
an image and I'm going to load sorry
wrong one let's load the earth clouds
these are 8k images you want to get the
highest resolution image as possible
that's awesome so we want to erase the
black and see through these clouds and
right now you know we have the earth
texture inside of this sphere here and
the only way
gummybear thanks for joining I know it's
late for you really appreciate you man
see you on the next one the only way to
see through this is to use basically
we're gonna cut out the black and keep
the white so if you go to the opacity
tab and we load the very same image you
should be able to there you go see
through the image just like that
so let's um let's actually tweak the
contrast here of the opacity map I'm
gonna scroll down drop a let's drop a
gradient on there and this is basically
just like a levels of basic levels and
let's crank the brightness so these
clouds
really be coming through and let's move
this middle slider around and see if it
does anything for us yeah that looks
pretty sweet and then we'll take the
black and make it just a dark gray see
if it starts to bring back some of that
detail
awesome awesome yeah definitely um soda
Mon Mon soda Monty
yeah the cloud the clouds did you bake
for sure so I'm gonna hit T and just
bring this down until you see the earth
and then boom there just right above and
if we have a camera here we go like 300
millimeters you see how it's like
pixelated that's because we're using an
8k resolution image you want to use a 16
K resolution image if you can so maybe
once we have our scene fully set up
we'll go to Google and we'll search for
a 16 K resolution image and see if we
can't get anything that's a little bit
bigger because you you're not gonna be
able to get close to this thing unless
you have a higher resolution image all
right so I think planets look sweet from
basically the side where it's mostly
dark you know so you just have like a
streak
you have a streak of yeah something like
that that's beautiful and what are we
missing here guys we're missing a few
things we're missing the I'm gonna go
back to 24 here zoom back in we're
missing basically the atmosphere and
we're missing the specular highlights
around like the ocean right we want the
ocean to shine so if we go back to our
earth material okay and we go to the
roughness tab right roughness basically
and I explained this to you guys before
right
as an example again you have specular
highlights on say the phone
there's no roughness that is 0%
roughness because you can see it like a
mirror a mirror would be 0% roughness
now something like this would be let me
see it get a nice little reflection off
of this it still has a reflection right
but it's a lot more rough the reflection
is spread out a lot more right so that's
what we that's what we want to do with
the water we want to increase the
roughness on the water so that the
reflection is spread out a bit more so
if we go to the roughness let's just
crank that to 0.2 and there you go
already you can start to see that look
start to start to come up let's go to
0.5 awesome save the scene now with
octane we have some really cool camera
features if you go to the camera tab
here and go to camera imager let's do
some cool stuff so basically you have a
highlight compression you can crank this
up and it'll save your highlights like
it's doing here what else do we have you
can load different lots different color
correction settings which is always
super fun but for now I'm just gonna go
linear set my game at a 2.2 you can also
a vignette your image which I'm always a
fan of so we'll do a little bit of that
you can crank your saturation you know
it's basically like color correction
settings over your final image but what
we want to do here is go to
post-processing let's check that on and
you can get some really cool post glow
and that's what we want so let's set the
bloom power to like 20 right now and
let's set the glare power to 10 and
usually I do the glare power is half of
the bloom power so if this if the boom
power goes up to 50 I'm a tab down and
set that to 25 next what I'll do here is
is set the glare blur to one and that's
really gonna just you know haven't be
more of an atmospheric kind of glare
then you know your your star look which
I think sometimes is nice but in this
case I usually like to blur it out and
this is far too much so I'm gonna drag
the cutoff which i think is a new
feature and then in the new octane and
just drag this up until it's just
blowing out just the highlights you know
it's just glowing the highlights and not
the rest of the earth glare amount let's
do let's start cranking these settings
like that's that's pretty cool yeah
that's awesome and we'll bring the
cutoff all the way bring it up a little
bit and you see it's getting the stars
to I don't want to get the stars so
maybe what we'll do is someone actually
mentioned rendering out a render pass
like a post pass and we can get rid of
the bloom basically will have bloom as a
post pass and will go into Photoshop and
will just erase the part that are on the
stars if any of you if any of you guys
are using the Spotify ambient playlist
give me a thumbs up are the vibes good
right now let me know
Nyoka it says I never do vignette in
octane it's a nightmare to comp vignette
only in post yeah I agree with you man
I'll definitely add that back it's it's
way better to do it in Photoshop you
have more control over it but for now
I'll just leave it let's keep going
so we have our clouds and I wish there
were more clouds I wish there were more
so maybe what we'll do is go to the old
Google and let's do something like earth
cloud texture and you should be getting
some cool results go to images and if
you go to tools size set to large maybe
go to settings go to advanced search
image size we'll set that to like 10
megapixels
let's go 12 megapixels hit that Advanced
Search and you should be getting some
pretty crazy images here this first one
let's see 8000 by 4 that's 8 K there I
know there's a 16 K 1 floating around
here somewhere
same for same for an earth texture
but this one definitely I feel like this
one definitely has more clouds in it so
oh this is the website yeah this is the
other website that has some nice
textures I'm going to copy/paste this
for you guys into the chat and let's
find a nice cloud texture here 8 K I
think there's a 16 K one somewhere 8 k 8
K so I'm gonna pick one that has more
clouds generally more clouds let's try
this one boom save that and let's reload
it so go back into clouds go to diffuse
let's load that image
hmm
interesting it it still looks like less
clouds on this thing we can honestly do
making another cloud material so it will
duplicate that again and we'll go to our
clouds we'll duplicate the clouds let's
set the radius to just another three
point four centimeters so it's gonna be
2006 let's reload our material place it
on the new clouds and switch these back
to the other cloud map and that should
give us some more clouds reload our
scene
you gather something in NASA has some
nice high-res textures heck yeah
NASA textures image textures on NASA
let's see here let's just try like NASA
cloud textures
oh here we go
hmm yeah oh my goodness 21000 bite wha
I'm just gonna download this cuz its
massive but let's keep going with our
scene will switch the clouds out in a
second I'm gonna take off the post glow
momentarily
do these images taking so long to load
oh my goodness
so I want to view this earth through a
spaceship porthole I think it would be
really really cool it'll give it a
different perspective than just your
everyday average earth shot so last
thing I'm gonna do though is I just want
to give the earth some atmosphere so
we'll do that it's actually pretty easy
with some octane fog if you make an
octane fog volume and I'm actually gonna
scale down our earth so that I don't
blow up the entire system with a huge
fog volume let's take this fog volume
let's bring it up let's take our earth
and let's Center it with our scene all
right so that's right in the middle the
fog is let's enter that as well right in
the middle I'm hitting T on the fog and
I'm gonna scale this guy up save your
scene because fog gets pretty intense
I'm going to walk in the edges of this
fog just so that it's encompassing our
earth let's keep going with it a little
bit more okay so you can kind of see the
sphere inside of this fog now it's
actually a really cool thing if you um
yo boss
thanks for the super chat man super
appreciate you loving the streams thank
you thank you thank you so much I hope
you're getting something out of this
we're learning something and if anything
just getting inspired to make something
cool yourself sweet
so let's um let's take earth let's
control drag it and drop it into the fog
volume and you should you should
get a little bit of atmosphere around
your earth so if you go to the fog
volume and go to medium scattering and
absorption okay let's set the absorption
to just white go back and set the
scattering to a blue you should start to
see a little bit of atmosphere in color
a creep in in
and let's take this volume here and
scale it up so it's encompassing the
clouds as well so we need to keep
tweaking the settings here
I think the absorption needs to be more
of a blue as well and right now it's
looking a little dim it needs to be
brighter so I think what we're gonna
have to do here is tweak the fog
settings here let's crank our scattering
phase up where's our Sun let's try and
find the Sun here we go starting to come
into shape here let's turn our glow back
on
starting to take shape I feel like the
volume the the fog needs to be brighter
so hmm what's the best way to do this
I'm just kind of messing with some
settings here and seeing seeing what
works oh there we go
so I took the volume step length down
but it looks like it's taxing the system
pretty hard but it did make it brighter
let's maybe take the density okay that
doesn't work density 200 and I'm just
finding a nice balance here I'm gonna
take the earth that is making up our
circular atmosphere I'm just gonna scale
that down a little bit okay
[Music]
there's some we're saying that a texture
with a fall-off node can do the
atmosphere
- oh you're seeing these little streaks
here as well
texture with a fall-off node I wonder
let me try something
let me just try something crazy let's
delete the texture off of the earth that
is making up our fog volume here I'm
gonna try something let's see let's make
a diffuse material let's drop it on the
atmosphere let's take it out of the fog
volume uncheck the fog volume and let's
double click this let's go to node view
and I'm gonna see if a fall-off map on
the diffusion would work let's crank our
values and see skew factor there we go
let's crank the skew factor so it's
there okay something like that right and
then let's also pipe this into the
opacity all right so not quite giving me
that blurry hazy look I'm looking for um
[Music]
what if I also piped it into a mission
so a mission is going to give you a glow
so whatever is white it will glow that
color let's
let's just try that ooh okay we're
getting closer and it's not as render
intensive but we also we don't want to
see the atmosphere on the dark side we
just want to see the atmosphere on the
part that the Sun is hitting okay yeah
RGB spectrum on diffuse agreed so um
let's go and just pipe in a gradient
into the fall-off and white will now be
like a light blue is that working is
that working
so I need to cut it off at this Eclipse
here on the backside on the backside so
maybe I could do that by changing the
fall-off map perhaps so let's just
switch it okay that's not working
[Music]
hmm yeah not quite sure how to get this
one going all right as far as color goes
it looks like y'all are saying it needs
to go into the emission there we go
who is that
soda Monty thank you thank you thank you
y'all dropping these these facts on me I
love it so let's see let's go like you
can really crank the intensity here on
that and we want to go pretty intense
because that's going to be how we get
our glow but we don't want it to be on
the back side that's what's killing me
hmm yeah not sure if I know how to solve
this one this is a tough one
um transmission let's see maybe a pipe
this in to the transmission let's see
what happens maybe what we could do is
render out a pass of this and erase it
in Photoshop on the dark side and yeah
Vincent the Video Copilot orb is amazing
for what we're doing right now so if you
guys have after-effects you can also
download that it's free and follow along
as well but yeah we're doing it in C for
D today and yeah the shadow side does
look like it's reflecting some stars or
something I think it's from the water so
yeah there's a couple little things that
we need to figure out here and yeah the
emission is causing it to emit light on
the dark side which is not what we want
we'll a simple gradient mat work like it
would have to be on you would have to
erase basically part of the image here
hmm I'm just stumped
so it's the opacity that's getting us
right
I wonder if Oh interesting okay there we
go that's starting that's starting to do
it and then I guess you would just have
to like rotate
you basically have to like rotate this
thing around depending on where your
shadow is at
okay it's not a bad idea
invert it once I get it to cover just
the dark side
oh man okay that's not that's not gonna
work
all right so here's what we'll do
instead of instead of focusing on
getting hung up on this atmosphere
business what we're gonna do is move on
and create the rest of our scene and
then we can start focusing on the
details so in the meantime let's just
get back to setting up this a window
this porthole deal I'm gonna turn off
this glow I'm gonna turn off the bloom
and I'm going to let's see we have this
fog volume that's kind of giving us a
little bit of this glow that we're
looking for but it's not the best but it
is giving us the kind of highlights side
atmosphere and no no madness fear on the
shadow side okay so let's see da or die
saying create a new node RGB spectrum
blue in the diffuse fall-off note in
opacity and boom yeah but here's the
thing is the fall-off note in the
opacity is not working for me I mean
like you're saying basically I mean that
that doesn't look how bad right there
actually but basically you're saying is
okay he's saying create a new node RGB
spectrum in the blue diffuse so RGB
spectrum let's see if this works
we have an RGB spectrum let's set that
to blue right so we have our blue light
here so don't want to thank you so much
for joining enjoy that dinner he's
saying if you make it a strong color and
make it pretty transparent you can get
the atmosphere showing without emission
and not have a problem
BRB okay yes you had the fall-off node
into fuse all right so let's just let's
just give this another try so the RGB
spectrum and the fall-off node is in the
you say opacity fall-off note and
opacity
wait a second wait
yeah I mean that's kind of working but
we okay why is that working
that's totally working well we want it
brighter
hmm yeah so is there a way maybe instead
of defuse it's a glossy material that is
set to a chrome with a ton of roughness
that's still not working
thanks for bearing with me all I'm
learning too
let's roll with this for now I
definitely make that edge brighter but
let's make a porthole so I'm gonna
actually make a new scene and let's um
let's see what we can do here so EMU so
today we are making a space scene and
all right now we're going to model a
little porthole to view the space scene
through awesome okay so if you go to
google and we we type like ISS porthole
you'll get some images and you always
want to reference stuff so something
like this you know basically like an
airplane porthole but circular a bunch
of different layers and bits of detail
around this is a nice one I like this so
let's let's try something like this it
has a few different layers to it there's
a lot of like metallic textures there's
this like a ring with different circles
in it I like this one a lot so there's
like a couple of gadgets here too so I
wonder if you'd be able to download it
from turbosquid as well let's try it
oh man okay let's go to free there is
one free porthole it looks like garbage
so let's do it ourselves y'all it's this
is a tutorial it's what we're here for
so let's go to tube let's make a tube
and let's flip the orientation to + Z
right and if you were a person I'm gonna
spawn a little figure here be about that
big right so I'd say this porthole is a
little it could be could be about the
right size let's bring the outer radius
down something like that and let's bring
the height down to something like that
and if you were looking through this
porthole you'd be something like this
right here pretty spacious so let's
delete the figure I'm just doing that
for scale let's save our scene we're
gonna call this porthole yeah you can
relate to the turbosquid moment washa
yes yes indeed you know why model it if
you don't have to right okay
let's crank up the polygons on this
let's go like rotational segments 100
and let's take the height down a little
bit more something like that and let's
let's just hold down shift and I'm gonna
use the little deformers here hold this
down and letting go on bevel and if we
come in here you can see that the bevel
is totally like breaking our model apart
which is not what we want and I wonder
if there's a checkbox inside of the tube
to kind of alleviate this and I don't
know if there is basically what you're
not to do is make the tube editable by
hitting C you have to select all your
polygons with ctrl a and then hit you oh
and that if you right click UO is Optima
you want to optimize your model and then
now the bevel will work and I'm just
doing I'm using a bevel deformer so that
I can have more control over this thing
I don't want to bake the bevel in so
let's set the subdivisions to like five
let's go like two back-to-back to zero
I think actually could be interesting if
we do like a second level of bevel but
you see how its beveling all of these
polygons around the model we don't want
that so we want to use angle if I check
that it's only going to bevel something
basically beyond the angle we have set
so you just crank the angle threshold
until you get what you want
boom that's what we want right there and
I like that hard edge you know that very
angular feeling so I'm going to go back
to the bevel hold down shift again hold
down the modifiers let go on bevel and
you should get a second round of bevel
on your bevel they should be working
check the use angle offset should be
0.25 and let's crank the angle until
it's actually doing something and
nothing's happening why is nothing
happening we should it should be to the
point let's see here it should be to the
point where we should be able to get a
double bevel out of this so maybe we
have to just do it again see hold down
0.2 5
put that in there or is it the other way
around why is that not working oh wait
there it is there it is okay so you just
need the first bevel first that's their
main and then below that you have your
second so I'll set the second one to
like point one and we'll set the
subdivisions to like three that way you
get a nice hard bevel but on the inside
you have a smooth edge right so that'll
be one layer if we go to our tube and we
select we hit ul we'll do a little ring
selection and we'll just select the
outermost edges and we'll hit T we're
gonna scale those up so we get a little
bit of like angle slice right there on
the porthole and that so now we need to
actually adjust the angle threshold boom
right there and then we'll do the same
for that one boom so now it's kind of
like beveling in right the portholes is
getting smaller as we get go down the
layers now let's take the tube and let's
duplicate this control drag to the
outside all right and let's see if we
can't get another layer in here let's
move it up and in a little bit more and
let's use that reference here and see
what things are looking like so you have
like a hard edge and then you have one
that is has like the dotted angle deal
on it so I wonder if you can use a
boolean object to chop little holes
outside of that so let's try it let's
take a cylinder here and scale it down
and pinning T to scale it down and
basically what I want to do is stick
little pegs out from around this window
and we're gonna chop that out so that
there's little holes right
at Lhasa yes I did just bevel a bevel
absolutely and it's all editable so we
can change those at any point so from
here I want to duplicate this using a if
I go to if I hold down alt and go to mo
graph I'm going to use a cloner and I'm
gonna clone this cylinder in a radial
fashion around this little tube we have
so you can see by default they're
getting stacked linearly above there's
three of them and in the mode it is a
lint it is set to linear so we're gonna
change that to radial and already you
can see how it's doing what we want it
to do so we just need to tweak a few
settings here let's take this and move
it so it's lining it's actually lined up
with this first one so let's leave it
that way
we need to scale down our cylinder so
that it fits right in there and we set
we set our tube to have 100 radial
segments so if we set our cloner to say
one account of 100 you should have one
cylinder for every polygon and if we
offset it start an angle if we offset it
just a little bit you'll be able to hit
each cylinder to each polygon right and
we'll adjust it so it's just in the
middle it looks like it needs to come
down a little bit more so to point to
that looks about right so now we have a
cylinder for every single polygon and
now what we'll do let's see here
let's take our cylinder we don't need
the cylinder doesn't need to be that
detailed so let's just set it to 12
rotational segments
maybe maybe 16 rotational segments that
should do let's try 18 24 24 it is 24
rotational segments johnny saying
instead of bullying fields would
probably be a good way to do the holes
on the window not sure fields I've never
worked with fields to be honest with you
man
um Fields is pretty pretty complicated
and at least in terms of you know myself
who had never messed with it but how I
don't know how you would do that using
fields instead of the bullying now
bullying is pretty render and not render
intensive but it adds a lot more lot
more polygons honestly I'd rather be
doing this in fusion 360 modeling in
another program and d8 or Die I don't
how to say your name he's saying I sent
a video in the tutorial suggestions
channel of the discord for the fall-off
node I will check that out when we get
back to it thanks buddy I really
appreciate you man bye fields you met
volume modeling interesting interesting
all right let's keep this up so
basically we want to take this tube
right we'll call this I will just leave
it we'll leave it as tube for now in the
cloner we'll just call this rivet holes
okay and let's make a bool object I'm
gonna hold down the little instances
here just hold that down it let go on
bool and the way I remember it it's
always a minus B so you a is your your
ring here so I'm gonna drag and drop the
tube into there I'm gonna uncheck the
bevels for now and then your B would be
your rivets so that will be a minus B
and right there you can already see it
getting taken away it's exactly what we
want so in the bull object here let's
create a single object will hide the new
edges we don't we don't need to see
those let's save it and let's zoom back
in here we need to bevel all these edges
so for the tube let's try turning those
on that looks great now we also want to
bevel the bull so I'm gonna right click
it and group it and then I'm gonna hold
down shift and drop in a bevel and it
just completely disappeared so maybe
instead of having these bevels on the
tube let's undo those and just do an
overall bevel let's set it to 0.25 or
maybe we'll take these original bevels
we'll bring them up into here and start
turning these things on and see what
happens okay it's disappearing I don't
know why it's disappearing right now
maybe the bull needs to be above the
bevel or maybe the bevel options are
throwing it off
is it the angle threshold it looks like
it is the angle threshold
so it's very subtle angle threshold 90
let's see 91 let's just turn off the
angle threshold deal
okay so I'm just gonna drop it right
into the bull at the bottom of that
Douglas the shrimp welcome we're making
a space scene right now I'm modeling a
porthole and I'm trying to figure out
how to bevel just these outer rings here
so let's see let's see it should this
should just work it's alright so that's
that's beveling those guys um I'm gonna
try making the cylinder editable and
optimizing the edges there okay there it
is there it is that's what we want
perfect I think I should how to optimize
let's use the angle and boom it's
working for us let's make it a little
bit bigger point one subdivision 3
awesome so that is our like rivet
section and what I'm gonna do here is go
back to our cloner control drag this up
and out so we just have our rivet holes
okay and let's make like a little rivet
so if we make a new cylinder hit s to
snap the viewport to the object we have
selected let's hit T and scale it down
hit s once again let us crunch this
thing down segments will go six height
let's just scale it down it's probably a
little rivet it would probably be 0.75
centimeters tall that looks that looks
about right to me let's make that
editable by hitting C or this button
right up here make editable we're going
to do a little bit of pre-work here
because we know if we hold down shift
and let go on bevel and set it to a
reasonable size point one it's going to
do this thing again it's gonna break up
our model we don't want that so we know
that we need to select our cylinder go
to the edges mode I'm sorry polygon mode
here hit control a and then hit you OH
and that will optimize our model and I
don't know why you have to do this it
should just be an automatic thing but
instead of hitting you oh all guys
remember your hotkeys of course but
right click and hit optimize right there
all right so let's check the bevel back
on we want to use the angle threshold
because we don't want to bevel these top
bits here just the outside let's make
the offset a point 0.15 that's good
right there let's take the Phong angle
because you can see like the shading and
the lighting is a little weird on this
thing let's just let's see let's set
this to to 2.2 that'll do it that'll
normalize things and then let's do that
double bevel situation again so I'm
gonna hold down shift with the rivet
selected let go on bevel bring it down
to a reasonable size point to 5 use the
angle threshold and let's just check
okay so it's bigger than our first one
we want to go 0.05 and drop it down okay
that's looking a little weird
let's go point oh one and just the angle
threshold so it's hitting all the edges
boom right there that's looking nice
and actually I kinda I don't want I want
to adjust this bevel a little bit more
there it is boom that's what we want
that's what we want right there all
right so now that we have this bolts
let's go ahead and place it in our
cloner that we duplicated so that's
called rivet holes let's rename this to
bolts and we will replace the cylinder
with with the bolt make sure you guys
name your stuff so we can stay organized
and now we have bolts inside of these
little holes that we had made here so
let's adjust the cloner here we want to
push them out a little bit further so
let's up the radius yep that's looking
about right let's go 51.5 fifty point
five fifty point eight so they're
sitting just in there and they need a
little bit of rotation because the holes
are angled inwards so let's go to
transform and rotate them on the Y until
they line up boom just about there and
then we do want to scale them up a
little bit so under the bolts cloner if
you just select bolts hit T make sure
you are in model mode so you select the
entire thing hit T and just start click
and drag and these things will start to
scale up and then from here you should
be able to randomly rotate all of these
by selecting bolts and going up to
mograph effector random and now they
just went all over the place but that's
okay if you go to parameter in the
random modifier here you uncheck
position and we want to check rotation
and I believe it should be the second
option the Y nope it might be the first
option yeah just set that to 360 now all
of these bolts will be kind of randomly
rotated in a different orientation to
give you a more natural look so let's
save that we have our little
bolt strip here let's adjust the angle
of the bevel on the bolt strip so that
would be under your tube and that's your
main bevel main bevel and this is micro
bevel it's the main bevel let's bring
that down to 0.5 there you go very nice
and I'm gonna skill these bolts down
just a little bit
awesome how's everybody doing everyone's
falling along let's go back to our
reference yeah it's like an awesome
let's let's make the bolts flush with
the edge of this thing so I'm gonna go
two bolts and set the radius to fifty
one point two five fifty one point two
and that's about flush with the edge of
this thing so that looks nice
just like our reference let's do a metal
strip in between these two dealies here
so let's go back to our reference and
see what's going on we have looks like
we have the bolt section and then
there's like a flat section okay
let's actually make this metal section
the front piece so I'm going to select
the let's see let's just use this tube
we have here and we'll move this thing
once cinema4d is done wigging out on me
come on see 40
what's going on why is it thinking so
hard
I'm gonna set my bolts to render
instance and I believe that will save on
some RAM here same for the rivet holes
we'll set that to render instance I'm
gonna just pause or I'm sorry I look for
some reason did something weird there
I'll set it back to instance I'm gonna
pause the render so we can just work a
bit more efficiently here let's select
our tube bring it forward right about
there and I'm going to actually hold
ctrl and make a new tube in place of
that and let's set it to plus Z hit s to
snap our view here zoom in and it looks
like our inner radius is set how we want
it to be so let's bring the outer radius
in let's scale this guy up and we want
to just match basically we want to match
this edge right there so let's go back
to our tube hitting s and bring the
height in will set the rotational
segments to 100 and we will walk this
guy in just a little bit like right
there let's scale it up
like right about there
awesome awesome and we will hold shift
select our modifiers here let go on
bevel and once again it's doing that
thing or it deletes the edges we don't
want that so we're gonna make it
editable and we will go to the edge mode
polygon mode ctrl a to select all uo to
optimize and now the bevel should be
working so let's keep adjusting our
bevel we want point two five but we
don't want to bevel these so we're gonna
use angle threshold it's actually set
pretty nicely and then let's bevel our
bevel so we're gonna hold shift again
let go on bevel bring that one down
below and we're gonna using a threshold
we'll set it to point one 0.025 and
we'll set the subdivision to one and
that'll give us a nice a nice little
ring here and looking at the reference
again it's nice and reflective so we'll
come in here with like a super
reflective material let's move this
thing back a little bit and then scale
it on the Z so it's a bit thicker
perfect okay um and then I think we need
like one more chunk which is kind of
like a forty five-degree
little Deeley here that connects it to
the glass so this will probably be like
a two pane glass thing let's duplicate
this tube I'm holding ctrl and moving it
and then I will let's see turn off
let's go actually go to edge mode hit ul
for a loop selection
tea and let's scale that guy up and in
and then let's actually take the entire
tube and scale that into and then bring
the edge in even more for that nice so
nice awesome and let's make sure the
bevel is working properly the angle
threshold needs to be tweaked yeah that
feels right and then actually I'm gonna
give it a bit of a curve so let's see if
we go to mm how do we do this let's go
to tube
let's hit KL and that's gonna give us
the ability to make a chop around the
whole thing and holding shift I'm
basically going to just snap it so it's
just in the middle
I'll hit ul so I just have that little
bit selected hit T and we're gonna scale
it so it kind of is doing a little ramp
deal here and I'm gonna do the same for
the midpoint of that section just to
give it a bit more shape
just so it kind of ramps up into that
and it looks like our bevels are doing a
good job
I want to bevel it even further so let's
change the angle threshold yeah so it's
getting those guys in the middle so it's
more of a ramp and finally I feel like
there'll be a pane of glass here right
so let's make a cylinder which will be
our first pane of glass will set it to
plus Z and right about there yep and
we'll bring the height down so it's
let's make it one centimeter it's a
thick one centimeter piece of glass boom
and then just on the outside of that
will be another tube set to plus Z as
well and this will just be like a little
connector piece between both panes of
glass this will also be let's make this
one centimeter as well let's see
rotational segments 100 and height one
centimeter we'll bring that in we'll
take the outer radius down so if the
inner radius is 50 let's just say 50
centimeters the outer radius will be 51
centimeters and we'll make sure that is
just on the outside here we'll scale it
down so it's coming in contact with the
glass right about there
perfect and then let's duplicate the
cylinder again hold ctrl move it and
that's our second pane of glass that is
in contact with space awesome so I'll
take let's just name this we got outer
glass
we got inner glass we have outer ring
this tube here is I don't know we'll
just call this outer tube the random
modifier we can bring to the bottom we
have bolts that's great we have null
this will be this will be rivet ring and
finally we would have our inner tube
let's save our scene here yeah that's
basically it we just need to texture
this thing
so let's just real quick throw some
textures down I know I want a like
chromed out texture for the outside here
so I'm gonna go to index and set that to
one the rivets will be also a reflective
material so I'm gonna copy that drop it
on the rivet ring as well as the bolts
actually the boats will be chromed out
so I'm just going to drop the Chrome on
there let's grab the roughness tab and
crank that up and then we'll set the
diffusion to kind of like a off greenish
we'll bring our specular down to like
0.5 maybe 0.75
I like a little space green-gray look
and then we'll have more of like a
blueish plastic for this final one so
we'll set that let's see we'll set the
diffuse to more of a blue but it's still
kind of grayed out
we'll go index on our glossy material
1.3 and we will up the roughness a lot
more on that and we'll come in for some
detailed texturing a little bit later
let's apply the same material to the
outer ring and for our glass that's
going to be an octane specular material
we'll drop that on the inner glass
control drag to the outer glass and
let's set the under common we'll check
fake shadows amazing
yeah that's super cool and we want to be
inside of this thing right we need to be
inside so let's make a cube let's make
it editable and just delete let's see
delete the one side there we'll move
this thing back and then we'll make
we'll make a cylinder set it to plus Z
and we just want to encapsulate this
thing we'll make that cylinder editable
bring it right up I'm gonna delete hit
you ul for a ring selection delete that
chunk we're just gonna like put a cap on
this thing and so that no light can get
in just like that don't scale it up a
little bit
and we'll select those outer points ul
scaled those up oh you got to do the
optimized thing select all hit uo to
optimize grab those caps again scale
them way up and move them back scale
them up even more and that'll basically
be the inside of our little space thing
we can delete the cube so our camera
will be inside of this thing but for now
I'm going to hide it in the viewport I'm
also gonna right-click and add an octane
tag to it and under visibility I will
uncheck camera visible visibility so
it's still like darkening the inside of
this little thing here and let's take
the outer glass the inner glass let's
also hide those from the viewport so
they're still in the scene but we just
don't have to deal with it here and
let's um take all this stuff and put it
in a null object this is called porthole
boom so we got that let's copy it and
paste it into our space scene how's
everybody doing
everyone following along
so Demonte says we should make the inner
part rubbery I'm down for that like the
in-between both glasses yeah let's do
that
let us do that so important all I'm
gonna hit s we're now in our space scene
the porthole is inside of the space
inside of the what am I saying anymore
guys I I have no idea it's inside of
Earth right now instead of monta thank
you so much man for joining I hope you
have good dreams peaceful dreams thank
you for the subscription and joining the
discord as well I'm glad you found the
channel as well good night all right so
let's make this last bit rubbery here
let's actually flip it around dang it's
a little crunchy a little laggy here
what's up Jake thank you for joining
appreciate you man
morning morning from Australia in
morning from the Philippines thank you
for joining pengie new Pankey new TV
welcome welcome
alright so let us take a look here we're
gonna add some details as we go but we
want to set up our scene just a little
bit more are we inside of our porthole
we are yes beautiful let's render the
scene and see what we got
I'm gonna take off let's make the
porthole visible and let's give it kind
of a darker texture here ooh there we go
now we're starting to get into some
space vibes here
alright so the porthole OOP just deleted
it
okay so we definitely want to go for
this vibe here it looks really cool it
looks very industrial I like the
lighting a lot you know we can adjust
the positioning of earth a little bit
I do like center framed things so you
know we might do something like this
that lens flare super cool - all right
I don't know I don't know why we're
seeing stars like through through this
little porthole business maybe it's not
a tight seal I don't know
but let's keep moving so basically let's
like take this frame here
a little space capsule
let's take this frame here and let's
actually drop this porthole inside of
our camera so when we move our camera
the porthole will basically just be
connected to our camera angle it will
always stay locked like this
that's going real slow on me
dang Northern Lights dancing on the
surface of the planet who would be tough
but I know we could switch it out for
the background certainly here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna hide the porthole for
now because my computer is slowing down
we're into the scene let's find the
right angle for our planet and then
bring the porthole back in
I think I don't know why it's so laggy
right now the heck
there we go
okay so yeah definitely fan of like this
Center view top view kind of deal
[Music]
so maybe what we'll do here is we'll get
we get closer to this thing like right
above the planet here so we can see some
detail on this thing and we want to
adjust the Sun so it's striking off the
edge of this thing so let's take our
light our daylight here
let's pop let's actually hit check
camera under options pop out of our
camera so we can still like we can see
what's going on but at the same time we
can look at our render and see what's
going on our render alright so under the
octane daylight let's just start moving
this thing around
and I think the reason why you're seeing
all these little speckles here is
because of the HDRI map and it's trying
to bounce the light onto the dark part
of the earth and it's actually not what
we want it's looking like stars from
space but I think it's just trying to
hit the specular of the water so under
earth I just want to like get this
highlight more stretched across the edge
of the planet so let's just crank the
roughness up and I also want some
specular detail on the land itself so if
we go to the specular map here that we
had set up and we drop a gradient note
on to that and we take the black and we
set it to just off off black so it's a
very dark gray you're gonna get a little
bit more specular in the landmass itself
let's take the normal bitmap and let's
set that to let's actually drag it into
our scene here hopefully we don't crash
fantastic let's drop that on to the
normal and crank that to like three
power of three you should get a bit more
detail in there it's a little intense
we'll set it to two and the clouds
should also have some bump so let's go
to the cloud map here and see if we
can't do the same so I'll just drag the
bitmap from diffuse into the bump tab
that might give our clouds a little bit
of definition here and let's turn on the
fog volume which is acting as our
atmosphere layer and it's kind of like
stuttered here you can see it it's
pretty stuttery
so that's not looking too hot let's see
if we can't just keep adjusting oh I
think I just hit the opposite Oh oh man
um let's go 100 with that whoa whoa
that's such a crazy look oh there's an
edge feather option in the man that
looks crazy
so I'm just messing with the fog volume
here and getting the right look
let's take the octane daylight and go to
the little tab here let's set the power
to two maybe even let's go five to
really get that intense atmosphere
across the planet I'm going to scale
down the sphere that is our atmosphere
just a little bit get that right vibe CG
studio thanks again for the super chat
he says you can do this by the way love
your hairstyle thanks thanks my
hairstyle is no hairstyle right now it's
just got out of the shower went to get a
bagel and came home to stream so I'm
appreciating it this looks pretty sweet
like this is a vibe right here you know
um let's let's see if we can't hmm it's
just gonna needed a lot of samples oh
man that looks that looks pretty sweet
game coder says hey Clint what are you
working on I'm working on a little space
scene right now um you know just get a
little something going here I think why
not do a space scene this is super fun
right now so we got our porthole that we
need to add in
all right so this is just gonna take a
while to render because of our fog
volume and the HDRI takes a long time as
well you know what might be a better
option
let's try because we could always add
the stars in later right
so for render times let's see if we hide
the octane skylight and we go to our
octane daylight right we set the sky
texture we uncheck that and we set the
sky color to black okay weird what's
happening now sky color is black but
we're still getting some gray what does
that gray from interesting um okay so if
we render with alpha then we'll be able
to kind of tweak this in Photoshop a
little bit
turning on adaptive sampling deep image
what is that I have no idea okay this is
looking pretty sweet
let's just go to Google and look up
earth close-up and see what kind of
images we get here yeah like this that
is beautiful something like this
basically what we're going for is
something like this yeah that's awesome
so beautiful
okay let's turn on the post-processing
[Music]
and see if we can't get some nice bloom
in our image oh yeah nice Ali Ali Baird
says to basically make an octane sky and
we'll go in here we'll set it to just
the color will go black zero zero zero
and if you set it to visible environment
it will basically just be your
background but it won't be affecting
your image in any way and if I turn
let's see if I turn alpha off then you
know it's just a background it's not
affecting our image so the glow is
really intense right now let's set this
to direct lighting we don't need path
tracing for this
all right so there's a video in the
discord here we're getting the
atmosphere to work is pretend it we got
a potential fix all right so let's go
into the discord group let's see here
yeah come on tutorial suggestions
awesome oh wow okay
so he linked me to a video tutorial here
create allistic earth with cinema 4d and
octane but honestly man I'm looking at
this I'm looking at this atmosphere and
it's not doing it for me you see how
like it's just one solid color and it's
not giving you a nice glow you know I
feel like I need that glow and it's it's
dimmer than the image I feel like and
you need a fall-off between the edge of
the planet and the atmosphere and maybe
I think that's maybe more of a style
thing but yeah I certainly want to go
for like an edge here that blends
together and if we go let's go look at
that spacing again I guess yeah it is
kind of giving you you see what falls
off here there's a gradient fall-off
right there that's what I'm going for
but with the other version you know it's
certainly it's a hard edge you can see
that hard edge right there
and especially since we're so close up
now this is something you could probably
do in Photoshop to be honest
and I'm gonna do the bloom in Photoshop
as well but let's get our porthole back
see what it looks like with the porthole
all right so I'm going to go to options
uncheck camera here let's pop out of the
camera view let's see what our porthole
is let's get this guy aligned with the
camera if we select our camera and we
hold down control and let go of the key
make an object it'll spawn something
right on our camera and then from there
we can take our porthole and use the
transfer tool here to basically transfer
our porthole right to that cube just
like that you can delete the cube we'll
take the porthole and we will scale this
thing down
I think the porthole is taking up all of
our all the RAM for some reason I
honestly hadn't restarted my computer in
a minute
and Nagy yes yes dirty fingerprints on
the glass is what is a hundred percent
what we're gonna do here and that is
that is the touch right there absolutely
don't you got a line this thing up first
alright let's flip this thing around
sorry this is so crunchy y'all
oh man a crack in the glass that'd be
bad news bears
still lining up this porthole here I'm
gonna make it nice and nice and
aesthetically pleasing
ooh here we go starting to get nice
Oh awesome awesome okay so let's um
maybe getting rid of the bolts will add
the bolts in last and the bullying will
get rid of that for now - that should
speed up our render a little bit
okay so I think definitely getting some
fingerprints on the glass here is gonna
be the move so let's just render a
region here let's turn off the fog
volume let's get like right up in here
and for fingerprints the Cornelius
Dominic finger prints are the best ones
they're free so let's go over to his
website I'll show you guys he's an
incredible look look at that look at the
detail on this
he's got dust and like scratches he's
he's the best this is the image you see
when you open up octane right here the
dude is incredible look at this look at
the detail he's got a cool little like
Mars scene here and he's got tutorials
on how I did this as well
cinema 4d and octane he is the master
but if you go to tutorials you scroll
down you're gonna eventually see
tileable glossy maps and he's got like
fingerprints in here you can download
those for free and that's what I'll be
using so if we go into the specular
material let's just see if we can't go
to roughness I believe is the tab we
want to drop these smudges into and
let's load some of Cornelius's amazing
textures
all right so it's really intense it's
totally blown out because the sun is
shining right at the lens here so what
we're gonna do let's try
let's just drop that in natty
put that into the roughness tab okay so
let's just start moving the Gama around
the tiling is strange so let's set the
projection to box and let's use a UV
transform to move it around a little bit
if you right-click it and soullow it you
can that for some reason that's not
working
let's move it around a little let's go
to the transform and just start moving
it so it's giving us this like weird
mirror effect so I think what I'll do is
instead of let me try something
let me delete the texture projection and
let's just go to the texture itself on
the glass right here
inner and outer glass we'll select both
of those
let's turn one off for now actually
let's select the one that's still on and
set that UV mapping to flat we'll see
that doesn't change down here reload our
scene I think that did it now are we
still able to control the transform yes
we are
wonderful okay so that works let's crank
up the gamma as much as it can go we'll
go to like 8 and let's just crank the
contrast of this further so I'm gonna go
to I'm gonna throw a gradient map on
this thing and just bring the darkness
down
now if I invert this let's try inverting
it let's set the gamma down to a lower
number now and crank the whites up still
it's still the blacks yep I think those
are the fingerprints and it's still
giving us a weird like symmetry effect
here like a Rorschach almost so once we
once we set up this the look right we'll
fix that let's set the white until I get
grayish okay and then let's actually
keep going here we'll set this almost to
a dark yeah
almost oh it's almost gone alright let's
go to transform let's take our scale up
to like two three even
well maybe it's a little big huh let's
set it to 0.5 and I'm just working the
contrast of this image here
oh man a reflection of a face would be
cool definitely see what we can do let's
scale that up let's go back to one and
it needs to be so subtle so subtle so
actually I think if we do if we add a
multiply node in here and we give it a
float texture we can control the
intensity of this thing so if it's zero
should be off but if it's 0.25 it should
just barely be there and that's that's
what we're going for so I want to make
another one of these so if I take the
let's rename this to glass one let's
control drag it and we'll call it glass
- because that's technically well I
guess the outer glass wouldn't have
fingerprints on it and just be the inner
glass so we don't need to do that
actually
let's delete that let me just try a
different smudge texture
what's up sugar Authority thanks for
joining man it's an honor to have you on
the stream here we're doing a little
space scene yeah I think hands hands
would be probably beyond the amount of
time we have on the stream right now but
I think it's really good idea
so yeah let's keep going here
all right so I think a nice little
detail here would be to get the focus of
the camera onto the planet and have the
porthole be a little bit out of focus
I think that'll add a lot all right so
let's see here let's hide the porthole
from the render and as actually yeah
that's all when you do hide the portal
from the renderer let's go to the camera
tag here go to thin lens and let's set
the f-stop to like 1.2 and we'll go down
the C let's go down to depth of field
we'll uncheck auto focus we'll grab this
little focus picker thing here we will
select the planet and then we'll uncheck
the focus picker and now when we turn
the porthole back on okay still not out
of focus let's see if we can move the
aperture around so that this thing gets
out of focus
maybe the f-stop needs to be let's just
try point 1 we just want to get some
depth of field feeling here and once we
have it once we see it okay yeah there
it is
let's go 1.4 refresh our scene
let's do focal depth it looks really
cool actually though let's just try 8
all right getting close let's set it to
2.2
and maybe eight was the right one so
real quick let's we just need to pick
our focus again so I'm going to turn off
the porthole in the render viewer and
select this color or the focus picker
choose the planet and for some reason
it's not putting the entire thing in
focus there we go that looks about right
and let's turn the porthole back on
refresh our scene let's set the f-stop
to 1224
it feels about right so I want to kind
of adjust this so it's coming at the
Earth from a different angle here so
let's see something like this we're like
right up against the glass I'm going to
set my aspect ratio here
sweet this is pretty cool let's take the
porthole drop it into the camera feed
and we can move around like this really
frame up our image here
and maybe get some tilt on this thing
something like that answer end of that
see what it looks like
all right I'm gonna go to this chrome
and up the roughness to get more of a
you know circular feeling here on the
reflection
and I'm just gonna Rhys elect our focus
points to move the camera around a
little bit let's maybe try and actually
get it a little closer
and let's put our earth inside of a
little group here so that we can rotate
it around and get the best position the
most aesthetically pleasing position
and yeah I definitely hadn't forgot
about the clouds it's definitely
something that needs to be done
let's take the earth and rotate it
around and see what it looks nice
that's pretty cool
going to hide the porthole from the
renderview
and reselect our focus point
alright let's see let's see if we can't
so this white little dot in the middle
is our is our which we call it our
little bolt that we have arrayed around
this little bit here and we'll we'll get
back to that in a minute
but let's see if we can't get some
actual reflections going on from the
inside of this thing on the glass so
let's see this would be it here this
material and I think if we just set this
to anything it'll give us you know not
just a black reflection but maybe the
inside of a space station so let's go to
google and type in ISS interior
sure let's just grab like this image
here and we'll use this as our
reflections so we'll load that
under the diffuse tab
that way it's actually reflecting you
know actually actual something rather
than just darkness it's better than
nothing
okay that's about we're about there
let's see about I mean the clouds they
feel pretty good to me let's see if um
why not let's just load those legit ones
in so I'm gonna go to clouds here and
let's see if it doesn't blow up the
computer if we load in the 21 K
resolution clouds image that finish
loading where was that
give me one second while I find this
thing
here we go
Wow that is crazy
save this here
while its massive its 200 megabytes for
one image that's incredible so we'll
wrap that around the earth there um is
there anything else we want to add here
it's three o'clock so we're gonna be
wanting to wrap this up here pretty soon
hmm
we can probably maybe switch out the
HDRI for something a little different if
we'd like
yeah the inside does feel a little empty
but I want to get the highlights on that
metal a you know to pop a little bit
more
so here's the oh this is nice again
these are the greyscale gorillas space
HDRI texture packs that they will be
coming out with later this year that is
that is awesome
that's so cool it's like a mist coming
off of the planet there
that's cool let's rotate this
just getting a little bit of like
atmosphere in there some cloud
atmosphere
I'm just kind of messing with the angles
here
and mess with the Sun
all right so I'd like to get the
interior or the reflection on the metal
here a bit shinier so I think
potentially one thing we could do is use
a light that isn't the Sun to kind of
give us more of a backlight because you
know after moving this around like that
that's actually not bad I just don't
want to show the inside of this thing
it's not it's not giving me the right
look and honestly I think we might just
want to like instead of making this
porthole a cone like this maybe we just
slice it down the middle here scale that
bit up so we're seeing less of the wall
something like that
that way
you know you get a bit more.you you lose
a bit more of like that interior
that's pretty cool and I think once I
save this out I'll mess with it in
Photoshop to really tweak the textures
and the colors and the highlights and
stuff
you
so I'm making an area light and I'm
going to go to set the active object as
the camera so that's actually really
nice way to position a light accurately
you can come in here and just I want to
give it a bit more highlight here on the
reflection around the ring so something
like that I'll go back to the camera
obviously that's way too much so let's
set the visibility check that off let's
go in here to the light settings and
take that down to one we shouldn't be
able to see it why is it doing that
why is it doing that
let's crank the power up to 100 again
and let's go to option check camera and
we'll select that light and we'll make
it we'll set it as the active camera so
now we can see kind of what's going on
here
trying to get that nice highlight on the
rim of this thing there we go
something like that
that's actually illuminating the bottom
side of the planet we don't want that so
if we make a plane and we move it up
here and our scene is actually fairly
small we don't we usually don't want a
small scene for for a space scene so
that's probably one thing I would have
taken back well block the light here
we'll set this will give it an octane
tag and we'll say it is not visible and
why is it still visible it shouldn't be
so strange
let's give it a black diffuse here that
way it's not bouncing any light it's
basically acting as like a flag to block
the light there you can see the actual
interior reflection of the spaceship
that's cool if we give the interior the
spaceship a little bit of light you
might be able to get some interesting
reflections but I do want to focus the
scene on the outside but that's so weird
why is it I don't know why we can still
see the plane
a VFX is a lot of troubleshooting and
right now we're troubleshooting
so the plane is blocking the light from
the area light and if we add an octane
tag to that you should just be able to
uncheck camera visible and it should
disappear in the renderer oh why is it
not working
maybe what we can do so that's being
buggy is take the light and bring it in
closer
turn down the power of the light
that feels a bit better
so let's go back in here let's see if we
what should we do should we do the
clouds let's try the intense clouds and
that'll be about it
so let's go into the node editor here
and under the diffuse tab let's see
let's uncheck clouds one just leaving us
with clouds here let's make sure we're
on the right one yes we are and let's
try and load this image this 21k image
here
and it's thinking very very hard fingers
crossed
oh my goodness it worked and we're going
to drop the same texture into the
opacity
awesome now we have our high-res clouds
we have our space image here and I think
I'm gonna push the contrast of the image
in Photoshop you can also do it in
octane if you go into here and just kind
of like mess and under camera imager you
can choose a color correction profile
and just start pushing the exposure and
the gamma and get some interesting
results I'm going to turn back on our
let's see let's turn back on the bolts
and let's turn back on the rivet holes
reload our scene
awesome so now we have the color
correction profile on here I think our
light hmm light could be a little
intense here I might be able to back it
up a hair
let's see yeah as soon as we start to
orbit this stuff it gets real crunchy
because of the the bolts and the rivets
ctrl shift Z to undo camera moves but
yeah I think I'm just gonna render this
thing out let's go to post-processing
and see if we can't get some bloom
coming into this shot
that's looking pretty sweet
well I think that's all the time we have
today we've been going for three hours I
might still keep messing with the
feeling of this I think I could always
tweak stuff to the end of time but guys
I really appreciate you joining if you
guys want to see this final image go
ahead and follow me follow me on
instagram @ underscore poni sure
underscore leave a little link for you
guys here in the comments but again yeah
thank you guys for joining and if you're
not already join the discord that's
where we can leave comments and the
images that we've made together we can
also leave tutorial suggestions for next
time and I still hear you guys about
bringing ran into do like a little
collaborative tutorial stream together
so we'll definitely do that and yeah get
on that ambient playlist if you guys
want to dream out to some relaxing tunes
but until next time I'll see you guys
next Saturday at 12 o'clock thanks for
joining
peace